privé évocation jeff vite humbert on ne
divorçait pas chez les mitterrand mais
derrière l'image affichée du couple
formé par daniel et françoise jamais
démentie et jamais prise en défaut
devant les chefs d'état derrière le
protocole la mise en scène officielle
une autre vie s'organisait quelques mois
avant que françois mitterrand ne quitte
l'elysée paris match révélait une
information extraordinaire le président
avec une fille mazarine sur ces photos
la maman anne pingeot est encore cachés
réalité françois mitterrand vivait
auprès d'elle depuis des années daniel
épouse mazarine la fille anne pingeot la
deuxième femme le jour des funérailles
du président les français constatent de
leurs yeux il y avait deux familles
mitterrand longtemps dans le plus grand
secret on ne divorce pas non plus chez
les chirac peut-être là encore une
question de génération jacques et
bernadette un couple uni depuis le
premier jour dans les jeunes années
maison son succès comme à l'elysée même
s'il y a une vie très privée dont madame
chirac elle-même dissipe un peu le
mystère dans son livre conversations son
futur mari était bel homme et puis très
enjôleur tréguer alors les filles ça
galopait il ya eu des moments difficiles
à l'heure actuelle à la première épreuve
les gens se quitte mon mari est toujours
revenue au point fixe les présidents ne
divorçaient pas c'est un ancien premier
ministre qui brisera le tabou en 1991
michel et michel rocard se sait pas à
chacun sa part de l'échec dit dans une
interview retentissante à l'époque celui
qui vient d'inaugurer le parler vrai des
politiques sur la vie conjugale
un homme divorcé à matignon une
situation devenue presque banale les
français n'ont été choqué ni parler
juppé alain rault maria isabel ni parler
jospin lionel et sa seconde épouse
n'est jamais comme en 2007 la vie privée
n'aura pris tant de place dans la vie
politique avec un même dénouement pour
les deux finalistes de l'élection
présidentielle le couple royal hollande
s'est séparé quelques mois avant le
couple sarkozy cette couverture de
magazine paru en 2004 semble bien loin